charny
belle champion du monde
le film s'appelle la petite reine
d'alexis durand brault le prendre l
affiche d'ici une dizaine de jours au
québec
un film largement inspiré de la vie de
la cycliste geneviève jeanson wii qui a
reconnu s'être dopé une histoire qui
bascule vous allez le voir entre réalité
et fiction
tanya lapointe dans la petite reine
laurence leboeuf incarne une cycliste
qui devient championne mondiale en se
dopant le personnage principal du film
porte le nom de julie arsenault mais ce
n'est un secret pour personne ce que
c'est l'histoire de geneviève jeanson
on s'est rencontrés avant le tournage
mal était aussi présente pas mal tout le
monde ce tournage était un petit peu
comme conseillère technique
je n'ai jamais touché à dlp haut de ma
vie geneviève jeanson a défrayé les
manchettes pour avoir été accusé de
dopage l'avoir mis publiquement avant de
tout avoué plusieurs années plus tard
enquête sur un des plus gros gâchis de
notre histoire sportive
c'est d'ailleurs le reportage du
journaliste alain gravel qui a inspiré
le film au réalisateur alexis durand
brault
moi je voulais comprendre comment il
avait fait pour mentir comme ça je pense
je préconise est dans une mauvaise
personne c'est pour ça je laisse je
comprendre ils ont même rapporté dernier
test que tu sur marque dans le film on
dit même jamais le mot epo éviter le
style biographiques au profit de la
fiction permettait une plus grande
liberté artistique
nous on faisait pour un film historique
lors sais pas
je les connais pas les parrains de 2,2
de geneviève jeanson et c'est à pau le
but du jute ma fille france qui dit ça
pour se prémunir d'éventuelles
poursuites ces histoires de jenson qui
remanie sept ans après lui avoir soutiré
des aveux alain gravel diffusa ledit
prochain ou en reportage la seule
entrevue qu'accordera geneviève jeanson
sur sa vie et sur la petite reine est ce
que ce film c'est l'histoire de votre
vie et je dirais que c'est extrêmement
véridique
au niveau de l'intensité les grosses
peines que je pouvais avoir le sentiment
d'être seuls de besoin de plaire à ces
choses là
alain gravel a vu le film toutes les
séquences là dedans le coup de téléphone
à son père qu'un reste silencieux
explique exactement comme ça la petite
reine revient sur les traces de la
cycliste avec des tournages en belgique
et en arizona
mais les personnages secondaires sont
librement inspiré de la réalité
notamment l'entraîneur joué par patrice
robitaille qui y existent il existait
même temps je pense que lui aussi sacré
115 parce que je pense y a maintenant
envie de tourner la page composée à
d'autres choses que j'ai l'impression
que c'est un peu ce en moins qui est
fait
non je ne serai pas de déterrer des
vieilles source l'abe a été réveillé le
grand public pourra départager la
réalité de la fiction dans la petite
reine
à sa sortie en salles le 13 juin ici
tanya lapointe est à radio canada
montréal